this is master were smoker Adam Gertler
and culinary director Michael Brown from
doghouse together they created the
craziest hot dogs possible the hot dogs
you'll see today are not on the menu and
are exclusive to BuzzFeed these sausages
are experimental in nature some of them
will and should never be made again this
one is a shrimp and jumbo lump crab meat
sausage the base is a puree of shrimp
with a little bit of garlic kind of an
old bay style seasoning some fresh lemon
zest lemon juice large jumbo lump crab
meat so I'm going to show you what we're
gonna do with Adam sausages and how
we're gonna present them for you guys
take this nice grilled seafood sausage
purple potatoes carrots and corn I made
it a oldie with Chesapeake Bay seasoning
and there you have it this is the wicked
pissah it's supposed to be sushi still
smells like sausage yep totally fancy
version of a fish stick maybe a little
too salty for my taste but it's still
pretty I'm just gonna need to eat more
a vietnamese-style pork influenced
sausages so it's all pork cilantro mint
scallions fish sauce shallot we're doing
it as more of like a bond me and we're
calling it our Bon Appetit just a little
bit of hoisin sauce pickled vegetable
matrix green lime mayonnaise and there
you have it that's Bon Appetit I'm
really excited about this
I love Vietnamese sandwiches I think
there's maybe a missed opportunity to
put this on French bread it tastes like
a very unhealthy by me this actually
tastes like more one of the more healthy
or hot dogs I've ever had it just tastes
a little bit like a mummy this is my
least favorite right now but still 10
out of 10 would eat again
[Music]
duck chicken and turkey and put it
inside of a sort of like a kielbasa
style sausage so there's fresh thyme in
there lots of fresh garlic onions and
then the sausage was smoked
we've lightly wilted some pea tendrils
with the foie gras fat onions balsamic
and fig and we've reduced that down to
like a jam generously season the foie
gras top that off
brown butter toasted hazelnuts give it a
little bit of crunch that's the menage a
flaw this is a sexy mother hot dog oh oh
I don't yes ten out of ten would eat
again it's definitely like more in line
with what I imagine like broth basically
sweet on top just hanging inside
everything is so good together I can't I
don't understand what's happening I give
you the surf and turf first what you
have is excellent quality Maine lobster
tail and rib eye steak in a sausage form
I'll put a little bit of wild arugula in
there it's gonna ladle a little Bernays
over crispy fried parsnip chips and that
is your surf and turf this is like
something that Willy Wonka would make
this may be the first one I'm not that
into it's so good this is lobster this
is a luxury dog I should be wearing a
tuxedo right now but I forgot it at home
fried chicken is such an American
down-home classic how could it possibly
have taken this long for us to come up
with a fried chicken sausage but that's
exactly what we did for BuzzFeed we
basically took the classic Southern
Fried Chicken flavors I'm talking about
your buttermilk marinade your fresh
thyme your garlic your mustard powder
your cayenne pepper salt pepper we put
all that inside the sausage we're using
a little bit of a vodka beer batter and
then we're gonna fry the chicken and
then serve it with a waffle sweet maple
and buttermilk kind of coleslaw dressing
pull that string out with a little
drizzle of honey your fried chicken and
waffle sausage this looks like the most
American thing
I've ever seen
there's like a warm hug this is amazing
always fries sausages this is what I've
learned this is the best thing I've
eaten today and maybe like will for the
rest of my life I was thinking oh my god
I can't believe I'm making dessert
sausage that's so disgusting why would
anyone do that and I started drinking
and then I said you know what why don't
I just put that in the sausage so we
have kind of an Irish Car Bomb influence
in the sausage cinnamon nutmeg allspice
maple syrup and then we finished it off
with dark chocolate and marshmallows
gooey gooey one in this thing here round
butter pecan sauce beautiful caramelized
bananas the worst dessert time for
dessert
okay this is what what there's mutinous
it does kind of taste like s'mores it's
good as weird as that sounds I'm gonna
be telling my grandchildren about this
you pan hot dog dessert proof
[Music]
[Music]